nueva alerta sobre el crítico estado de
los derechos humanos en el mundo este
lunes la alta comisionada de naciones
unidas michele bachelet hizo sonar la
alarma ante la comisión reunida en la
sede de ginebra
la representante enfatizó en la
situación de las mujeres en afganistán
bajo el régimen talibán al que acusó de
incumplir sus compromisos de las últimas
semanas y pidió un organismo dedicado a
monitorear el respeto de las libertades
individuales en el país asiático
importante and es importante destacar
que contrario a lo que ha dicho el
talibán sobre las garantías de defender
los derechos de la mujer durante las
últimas tres semanas se ha ido
excluyendo progresivamente a las mujeres
de la esfera pública en muchas zonas se
les prohíbe aparecer en lugares públicos
sin un hombre y en numerosos sectores
profesionales las mujeres se enfrentan a
crecientes restricciones representantes
del talibán ha limitado el acceso de las
niñas a la educación en varios lugares
le prohíben a las niñas mayores de 12
años asistir a la escuela
señora presidenta estoy consternada por
la falta de inclusión del llamado
gabinete interino que no incluye mujeres
y pocos pastor yunnan pastores por otra
parte michelle bachelet emitió una
advertencia global el cambio climático
es la mayor amenaza a los derechos
humanos de nuestra era entre otras cosas
la alta comisionada también lamentó la
falta de acceso a la región de xinjiang
para monitorear el trato la mente
denunciado de las autoridades chinas al
pueblo uigur y aseguró que la comisión
publicará a corto plazo un informe con
los datos disponibles sobre la situación
en la región
por otro lado bachelet también señaló
las violaciones de los derechos
políticos en nicaragua por la represión
a los opositores del presidente daniel
ortega de cara a las elecciones de
noviembre